So let's talk about shapes as variables. Here are the two important points I
wanted you to think about. First, is that variables can be assigned a value and
replaced. Just like this circle. I could have had a triangle minus 5. I take
this symbol, the circle, or this variable, and replace it with this assigned
value, of 5. The other important part, is that some variable are unknown. And
there value can vary or change. This happened with my triangle, I can plug in
any number for my triangle, for example, the triangle can be 10, so that 10
minus, which would equal 5. Or the triangle could be negative 31 and I've had
negative 31 minus 5, or negative 36. Or the triangle could be a 1035, and I
would get 1030. The triangle could take on any value. This is a powerful concept
in Algebra. The idea that a variable could take on any number. We'll return to
this idea later. For now, just remember that variables can be unknown. And the
value can change or vary. Your probably not use to seeing shapes when doing
math. You're probably use to seeing x. Mathematicians have usually used x. And
it actually originates from the Arabic langauge, it means something unknown.